Shawn is with us in Oklahoma hey Shawn
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you sir I appreciate the time you didn't
sure how can I help I have a pretty big
question and um I'm a general contractor
in the oil field I'll give you a little
bit of background about myself like I
said on the general contracting the oil
field I've been one for about six and a
half years now and I've accumulated debt
I owe I owe on a truck that camper I had
student loan debt I'm in shock I'm
seasoning some hospital bills but my
biggest problem is I've been pretty
responsible and having done taxes since
I started general contracting I do have
a CPA working on anything right now the
process is still going on right now that
my other problem is unfortunately I have
a felony charge that I cannot afford to
fight anymore um work is pretty
inconsistent of the general contractor
and I can't even say for baby step one
right now and I'm wondering whether I
should try and take care of my debt or
if I should try and dispel any more and
just put everything I can possibly make
towards getting another lawyer well yeah
obviously I don't know the details on
the felony situation but when I hear
that word it scares me honestly and that
because that typically means jail time
yes I've already served my joke um oh
you already have yes sir I have so what
are you fighting then I'm trying to
appeal it and I have an assault and
battery on an officer and unfortunately
it looks very very bad on paperwork but
I didn't do the charge and I listened to
the wrong advice from my lawyer I should
have had someone else but it is what it
is now and I only option is to fight it
if I choose to
yeah so did you plea it out I pled no
contest because that was my lawyers
recommendation and it was a bad idea
because now it's you got this huge black
mark on you yes okay and so hasn't have
you talked with an attorney that gives
you hope that it can be overturned I
talked to a lawyer in Oklahoma City for
the appellate court and he said he
charged me a $5,000 retainer to file the
paperwork to appeal it the appellate
court denied my claim and he said
basically he's done at that point and if
I choose the even for anything else
it's another five thousand I obviously
cannot upload that every time I thought
about getting a different lawyer the
appellate court enigma denied your claim
what's the next step they said I can go
through the felonious court system and
then after that it's Supreme Court if
they deny my claim how are you
I'm 31 and I just turned 31 last year
what do you make I'm one year when life
is good and you're out there working
hard and you're not distracted what do
you make I can make up to 600 a day
almost I can make it more from 10 to 20
grand a month
yeah but works very inconsistent and
I've been struggling for quite a while
now I'm about to give up on everything
honestly does this does this felony
charge keep you from doing that work no
it probably doesn't know yeah they
probably couldn't care less in the wall
field okay no it keeps me from being a
company employee in a lot of spots
unfortunately sure cuz I have to about
several application done sure honey
when was when was the flinger the no
contest and time served when was on 2017
night I put another contest in the judge
game so how long have you been a lil
I've been out almost two years now okay
we're in Oklahoma are you I haven't told
them okay all right
um well I have a son that's about your
age
alright and so what I would tell him if
he is in exactly your situation is this
you have been through a life-altering
situation you've been through a mess and
there's probably a lot of value for you
in putting it behind you I don't know
anything about criminal defense just
some vague understanding of all of that
so I'm not an expert on this but it
sounds to me like when you're down to
your only option is basically you know
two options one of which is the Supreme
Court I'd say your chances are pretty
slim to none that you could throw a lot
of good money a lot of energy and a lot
of distraction after trying to get after
trying to get your name cleared and it
probably never happens that's what it
sounds like to me I'm just listening to
a very short version of your very long
story though so I know that based on
based on what you told me I think
there's a great value for you
spiritually emotionally financially in
putting all of this in your rear-view
mirror and step on the gas and head off
into your future with a smile and let's
go make a bunch of money and work our
butts off and clean up our debts and
pile up a bunch of money start and run
your own business in which case by the
way you work for yourself and you don't
need a you don't have a need for a
background check on it with an employer
or something like that I did not have a
felony conviction I did have a
bankruptcy that I filed when I was about
your age at chapter 7 bankruptcy and it
does leave a mark and there's some
things that even now 30-something years
later when I fill it out it doesn't
count that much against me now but it's
still some places that they just don't
want to you know you can't do that if
you ever file bankruptcy so forever I
can't do that and forever you've got a
felony and so you're gonna you know
you've you've lost some rights you've
lost some some access to some things
forever
I don't know that you've got a real I
don't know enough about it cuz I'm not
an expert but what you told me made me
sound it's several years behind you
you've had legal advice that took it to
a pallette court they slammed your door
shut on that I doesn't sound good man it
doesn't sound like you're gonna you
could spend a hundred thousand dollars
and get nothing in ten years of your
life and get nothing on this meanwhile
you could have gone ahead and had a life
and so I'm gonna recommend you go ahead
and get a life there's a great church
there in that town that's a good friend
of mine named Craig Groeschel has a
church called Life Church TV and I want
you to go call those people and go sit
down and talk to one of their pastors
and I want you to get some advice more
than just this radio show because I
think you need somebody that's guiding
you and your spiritual walk as well as
your emotional decisions because you
have been through hell and I want you to
get I want you to have a bright future
and it's probably going to require you
put some stuff in your rear-view mirror
and move on